oh well i've already run into some
issues here locally i will say this
at the parks here i took a little bit of
bread out there
you know i took some biscuit out there
to the lake to feed to
some ducks and you know me man if i'm in
a new area i like to get acclimated with
the animals bro
i'll pet an animal you know i'll pick a
snail up and walk three or four feet
and set him down you know save him
[ __ ] five days of travel
that's who i am you know i'll pet a dog
i'll whistle at a falcon i'll [ __ ]
you know i go out and feed a duck i see
a duck i feed a duck and i give a duck
bread right
but i give him biscuit i had breakfast
they had a half a biscuit left you know
i'm watching my figure since i'm doing
mma now
i'm straw weight i'm currently female
straw weight
and uh
and so next thing you know i'm feeding
biscuit man and these ducks are fired up
uh these ducks are really keyed up you
could see ducks in the distance looking
you could see ducks that haven't even
been born yet you could see a duck peek
out of the egg
you know just hearing that there's a
kind of a new boss man in town
you know a new [ __ ] yeast santa you
know i'm out there delivering goods
so i'm feeding i've got you know i got
half of a nice biscuit and this is an
expensive biscuit it's probably a two
and a half dollar biscuit
so we're looking at a dollar 25 worth of
biscuit bread i'm out there feeding
these bastards over there at perennial
lake or whatever it's called perennium
lake
by the jester uh by the vestibule or
something
so anyway i'm feeding them next thing
you know i started getting i put
on my instagram story i start getting
dms people angry you can't give them
bread
you can't give them bread you know
they'll die
you know they'll oh this is what they
they said oh
if you give them bread they get too
jacked up on energy
and they will rape each other
look man i'm not doing all that
i took a half a biscuit and went out
there to treat these animals
to get acclimated to the area
if somebody else if they're doing all it
you know i'm not doing part of
sexual abuse for animals i'm not doing
any of this
if they don't want bread they just
shouldn't come eat it that's not on me
people attacking me you're going to hell
bread
boy and then sending me two uh
caskets and a picture of a duck emojis
man
that's mother nature man if there's a
glitch in her pattern they will
she will work it out and these ducks
look like they wanted the bread that's
the thing
you know it's like oh they can't digest
it they will rape each other
well look man i'm not i didn't come to
town to be part of that
you know i'm not doing those sex
trafficking i'm not doing that kind of
stuff i'm not doing you know
i came here i just you know i'm trying
to get acclimated to the area good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one